[Music]
like a long road trip to a far off
destination there's been incremental but
steady progress in the development of
self-driving cars in fact some form of
driver assistance technology mostly
focused on safety is now inside most new
vehicles right now we're at level two
with cars able to control steering
acceleration and braking while still
requiring drivers to remain engaged down
the road level five autonomy would mean
fully driverless cars but the transition
into the future hasn't always been
smooth as the technology advances
drivers adjust and the government
tries to keep up brook silva braga hit
the road for an
update are we ready okay we're ready if
you haven't been in a new car for a
couple years i'm gonna push this
steering button here all right a ride in
a 2022 honda civic can be a trip so i no
longer am doing anything with the pedals
or anything with the steering wheel it's
doing all of the driving yeah in the
right setting the modest standard issue
honda civic can drive down the road
itself then smoothly brake behind a
stopped car an elegant stop i've done
nothing researcher kelly funkhouser
tests self-driving features for consumer
reports all of these cars have the same
technology we met at their connecticut
test track these ones here generally
have radar maybe sonar behind them here
you can see it's a camera those sensors
have enabled some impressive features
the new gmc sierra with hands-free
driving a growing number of vehicles
that can control both their steering and
speed are marketed with names like
supercrews so i turn the turn signal on
and it's looking
okay and it is changing the lane here we
are
by now you've probably heard about
waymo's self-driving taxis in the fleets
of autonomous tractor trailer trucks
coming down the road and sitting in one
of these new ordinary cars it can feel
like the self-driving future is as close
as that patch of grass over the hood of
the car okay what if you just leave it
on and we're about to hit a dead end
it's just going to drive into the trees
let's find out
you're bold you must know the answer
oh
oh
whoo
and into the grass we go
honda told us the system's not intended
or capable of detecting the end of a
road and is not marketed or considered a
hands-free technology it's the driver's
responsibility to maintain control at
all times and then this line is not
marked very well but it found it but
funkhouser worries these systems work so
well most of the time many drivers won't
be ready when the inevitable exception
pops up oh it's not doing that well yep
and there it turned off there's a
tendency to find a stimulus because
you're bored monitoring a system that is
performing well is extremely boring but
the problem is the features aren't quite
up to speed yet in their capabilities to
illustrate what can happen if a driver
fails to take control when they should
funkhouser put this cadillac escalade
into supercrews it's checking to see if
my eyes are looking at the roadway it
can skillfully navigate 200 000 miles of
american highway cadillac went and
surveyed the roads yes they did but
automatically disengages when it reaches
merging lanes that aren't part of the
map okay here we go oh wait why is it
reading us oh because this lane is going
to end so now it's actually oh my
goodness we're stopping in the middle of
the highway take control of the vehicle
now wait oh my goodness
cars are there okay yikes wow
boy driving with you is uh adventure
for all automakers the promise of
self-driving is both convenience and
safety but neither have fully arrived
quite yet
is the person driving or is a person not
driving
because if they're driving then this
stuff seems pointless and if they're not
driving then you can't ask them to drive
at a moment's notice exactly right and
that's what they're saying is they're
giving you the little legalese warning
take over because we don't want
responsibility you must pay attention
even though it's boring and we know that
you're a human being and that you're not
going to but we don't want
responsibility because we know that our
system's not perfect that's where we are
we're heading for chicago please route
us through we've been promised so much
more you're now under automatic control
in the 1950s gm imagined self-driving
cars by the 70s
in 2018 they promised them within a year
our goal is to deploy these vehicles in
2019 so you'll have the option to not
drive elon musk said a tesla would
self-drive across the country by
2017 it still hasn't instead the company
faces federal investigations and
lawsuits over some alleged instances of
failure of its autopilot system
and remember those waymo taxis use
high-end sensors far too costly for mass
production vehicles even those
autonomous big rigs still come equipped
with human safety drivers
so what happened a lot of people are
finding out that developing for all of
the chaos of the roadway is a lot harder
than anyone ever thought
last year elon musk conceded he didn't
expect self-driving to be so hard it
just turned on the turn signal it's
going to take us left here to follow
this route then he launched an audacious
plan to solve it we have the green light
sees it putting a full self drive system
on real roads and using carefully
screened tesla owners like bijan amazari
to chaperone the cars as they worked on
their driving this guy kind of went for
it so then it stopped
okay and there it goes the system does
much more than the civic or escalate
come to a complete stop here yeah just
barely that's a proper stop and the idea
is all these test miles will teach
tesla's system in ways only the real
world can can you really trust all these
college kids not to jaywalk no here they
come they had the don't walk they didn't
listen nope well you didn't really go
you were like i'm stopping now they're
running across
oh oh don't go now kid now's not the
time we made it
tesla didn't respond to our request for
comment but has described these beta
tests as a safe way to make their
software better i think it's going to
get us in the right lane now some
critics argue it's a potential menace to
anyone on the roads you feel it's ready
for
to do this to make this turn off the
exit to drive around town
safe for you safe for everyone else
under supervision of somebody who knows
how to use the software i'd say oops
sorry
at that very moment we missed the guard
rail like maybe a foot we came close
times like that are why consumer reports
wants automakers to only enable these
features for drivers who agree to
compromise their privacy and be actively
tracked as tesla and gmc drivers to an
extent already are
otherwise funkhouser doesn't trust
drivers to actively watch these
imperfect systems which could need
watching much longer than we'd hoped
i don't think you can order a car
pick you up from your house take you to
work until probably twenty fifty
twenty fifty fifty fifty that's what i
said five zero five zero so we're what
just under 30 years away from that still
funkhouser says the biggest thing that
would help self-driving cars is if they
could communicate with each other and
objects around them but that also may
not happen anytime soon in the last days
of the trump administration the fcc took
away most of the radio spectrum that the
cars were planning to use unless that
changes experts including funkhouser
told us it will be much more difficult
for cars to communicate brook first of
all thank you for putting your life on
the line i know right for this piece i
mean it can get a little scary when
you're when you're there and you turn it
over to the system or don't right you
know you sit in that tesla and it feels
like a miracle the thing really does
drive itself you're like the future is
here and then in a moment you're like
wait a minute this isn't working at all
because there are people and things that
even the cars can't prepare for and that
feels like the problem they either all
have to be self-driving or not i have a
suggestion if folks don't want to drive
it's called uber lyft bus
train how about that it's an idea for
options thanks brooke we appreciate it